tras pasar tres meses en Florida el
expresidente de Brasil Jair bolsonaro
retornó a casa en un panorama político
diferente al que dejó al perder las
elecciones ahora se espera que asuma el
liderazgo de su partido libre y que
enfrente las causas legales en su contra
como la investigación o por su supuesto
papel en la toma de Brasilia en enero
pasado sobre su regreso y su influencia
ahora desde la oposición vamos a
conversar con Daniel rayman quien es
abogado y profesor de derecho penal en
la universidad Federal la fluminense
Muchas gracias Daniel por estar en
directo América buen día
Buenos días es lo que agradezco la
invitación y la posibilidad de
participar en su programa a nosotros a
usted por su tiempo le agradecemos y qué
problemas se enfrentará bolsonaro tras
su llegada a Brasil
bueno son muchos y de varios frentes
tiene problemas y cuestiones para
explicar como la cuestión del ingreso de
joyas de Arabia Saudita que eran para él
y para su esposa
eso está actualmente en trámite en la
Policía Federal por delitos graves que
puede ser desde de camino a inclusive
crímenes de corrupción o peculato si se
considera que esas joyas fueron forma de
pagar
alguna ayuda al gobierno árabe en
cuestiones aquí en Brasil más eso está
en una investigación muy incipiente
Entonces todavía digamos está en esa
fase inicial de esclarecimiento más es
un frente que preocupa no solo a él sino
al grupo inclusive a la sigla el partido
liberal porque eso en cierta medida
mancha la imagen así de persona impoluta
limpia no y simples que siempre intento
mantener en los medios de comunicación
por otra parte está también los ataques
a la democracia antes de las elecciones
y después inclusive con la toma Palacio
en la implantada de los ministerios no
en enero pasado eso también es otra
fuente de de preocupación
entonces ahí se dividen en dos en dos
hechos no anteriores y posteriores a la
pérdida del mandato Daniel con esos
antecedentes Cuál será el nuevo rol de
bolsonaro en la política brasileña En
qué medida impactan estas
investigaciones al expresidente en
términos políticos
y mucho Yo creo que todavía no está muy
definido qué es lo que va a pasar qué es
lo que va a hacer en a lo largo de su
mandato las acciones judiciales se
fueron moviendo en función de
la intensidad con que la ha comunicado
con la la sociedad
si él mantiene un perfil más callado
como hasta ahora tal vez las cosas se
fríen un poco y y pasen un poco más
light digamos así a situación de
si él al contrario va a ir al embate con
las instituciones que es lo que ha hecho
hasta ahora yo creo que ahí las cosas se
van a complicar y el partido liberal
está un poco preocupado con eso Cuál es
el frente tanto es así que comenzaron
para mí con un plano B que es la la
viabilidad de Michelle bolsonaros su
mujer como presidenciable para las
próximas elecciones en expectativa de
que hay otro frente que yo no referencia
y que es en la justicia electoral donde
hay transacciones y donde de ella sí
llegar en a buen Puerto digamos así y
probar los hechos la responsabilidad
terminarían tornándolo inelegible por
ocho años lo que lo dejaría fuera de las
próximas elecciones Y eso le diría que
es más concreto Eso sí es más posible
que ocurra Bueno usted estaba hablando
de que ha mantenido cierto silencio
bolsonaro y que podría esto calmar un
poco las causas en su contra te quiero
preguntar por esa ausencia de estos
meses de
auxilio auto impuesto de los que hemos
hablado para qué sirvió este tiempo sin
agitaciones directas por sus comentarios
finalmente fue su actitud previa a las
elecciones la que inspiró las protestas
que se dieron después de la victoria de
Lula da Silva
Sí más después de todo no deja de ser un
expresidente Entonces yo creo que los
tribunales toman eso en cuenta y a
partir de ahí han regulado no el supremo
tribunal Federal es un tribunal
constitucional y político también y
Alexander Morales yo creo que ha
calibrado en las respuestas del tribunal
y de él como ministro a las reacciones
del propio bolsonaro por eso cuando
bolsonaro ha sido más enfático en sus
palabras el tribunal también forma
simpático en sus acciones y lo contrario
también es verdadero no obstante como él
ahora es expresidente él pierde la
prerrogativa de foro esto es que se ha
juzgado por el supremo tribunal Federal
entonces las acciones de él van a
depender de jueces de primera instancia
sea en Brasilia sea también en San Pablo
en un caso de joyas Y eso hace que la
interferencia política sea un poco
diferente no porque los jueces de
primera instancia son jueces de carrera
designados por concurso público y son
concursos muy rigurosos entonces
ahí vale más la técnica que propiamente
la estructura partidaria entonces
ahí no sé cuál va a ser la incidencia
real en términos políticos que va a
tener bolsonado si usted ve en el caso
de las joyas el gran problema fue un
inspector de la
del sistema de ingreso de mercaderías
alfandario no que justamente como era un
funcionario de carrera no no
quiso hacer la vista gorda y aprendió
las joyas y instauró los procedimientos
correctos establecida la ley con
Independencia si era un ministro que
traía las joyas o si era un militar
en representación del poder ejecutivo
que pedía la devolución de las joyas
nada de eso ocurrió Entonces cuando los
funcionarios son de carrera aquí hay más
garantías no de legalidad como ya nos
quedamos en tiempo para mi última
pregunta rápidamente le pregunto ya más
allá de la postura de Yahir bolsonaro
frente a las ramas del poder Cómo evalúa
usted su apoyo Popular en las calles
después de las presidenciales
tiene un voto cautivo de para mí un 30%
que se mantiene firme y fuerte y no es
eso lo que termina definiendo las
elecciones
y le diría más el bolsonarismo es más
fuerte que el propio bolsonaro o sea los
partidos que llamamos de Centro que
defienden mucho de las ideas de
bolsonaro han tenido una posición
mayoritaria en las últimas elecciones a
diferencia del propio bolsonaro o sea
ahí bolsonaron no generó esa adhesión
como generar un diputados y senadores en
la exploración y en el avance de esas
ideas Entonces yo creo que está faltando
Tal vez un nombre que lo sustituya y tal
vez sea Michelle bolsonaro justamente
ese nombre que que lo va a sustituir
para poder el partido liberal continuar
con con su trayectoria política y yo
creo que él va a ir en declive con el
pasar del